foreign
Clarissa is up next in Houston Texas
that's John deloney territory
come on Clarissa how can we help
hi gentlemen thank you for taking my
call
um I am expecting my fourth child here
in a few months and
um I want to upgrade in car right now I
drive a CRV which cannot physically fit
all the number of children that we have
of course myself and my husband and I'd
like to get a a Model X Tesla and um
makes sense now forgive me I really
don't know much about Tesla's our
colleague George I would like that car
too yeah yeah he George has got one
Rachel's got one they love the old Tesla
but will that fit the whole family
uh so myself my husband and our four
children yes with a six seat
configuration yeah it was at six seats
but what for a few uh car seats and the
luggage for when y'all travel
so for the luggage we'll have to get
creative I found like a mobile
trailer that we can attach that's super
cute that can go with a hole it's super
cuter
hey you are how much is this car
oh clear so I'm trying to be nice yeah
how much is the car
so the car I'm looking at a used model
and so the range is about 86 to 90 000.
can you afford said Carr meaning pay
cash
yes I can I just don't know if I should
no you shouldn't well you can hear your
voice please break down that total voice
change doc I feel like there's something
there yes this is some this is somebody
who absolutely knows the answer to the
question here's what you're wrestling
with who you still want to see yourself
as and reality oh
reality is you're an awesome cool mom of
four an awesome cool wife and y'all are
doing life
in in your fantasy you're still Super
Rad and cool and you're still going out
to Fitzgerald's out there and why I
guess they tore it down you're still
going out and doing cool stuff and
you're driving a Tesla to get there
is that fair
but I am a cool mom
yeah I know there's no Mom in a Sienna
too is what I'm saying what's your
what's your annual take home household
um annual take home is about 330 000.
okay do you have any debt at all
um we owe 424 on the house okay so no
debt but your house
uh what's the other car worth the the
car maybe your hubs will drive
uh well my husband actually has a Tesla
of course he has a model three he's
still a cool guy he's still cool and I'm
over here at the CRP okay
um yeah boring mom while husband's off
being cool plugging his car in so you
got the cash that we would get rid of it
would be worth 20 000. all right so
you've got it you've got the cash right
now you can go buy it right now
right is that the fully funded emergency
fund I'm trying to find a hole here John
this isn't a math problem they've got
the money does it make sense yeah does
it make sense well I think it comes down
to I mean based on the formulas yeah
yeah that's what I'm saying this isn't a
math problem you can afford the car and
so there's our principals get it then go
ahead and do it in terms of
is are you going to be happy with this
purchase long term for your family and
are you buying a 90 000 depreciating
asset for four kids who are of a certain
size now and in five years they're going
to be double that size
all crammed into they're gonna destroy
this car you know this right they will
be walking
no there's
there's smashed in there gummy
it's gonna be a car I I wouldn't do it
on that alone I didn't think about that
Ken I would buy a car to get me through
the next five years until my kids to get
the sweet time right can go to the
bathroom on their own let's let's start
there right and then get a Tesla Maybe
by then they'll have Tesla minivans I
mean Clarissa the way you your
intonation changed you were like I know
you you know like what but what I want
to know why you called us to get our
opinion two dudes that you barely know
what are you doubting what feels weird
about it tell us
um well I I know math and I know that
there's a reason why I've driven this
CRV for this number of years I know that
cars are depreciating asset it doesn't
make sense but I also just like I'm
spending about two times longer in my
car every day than I used to I have a
newer job
so I'm like well if I'm in here like an
hour and a half a day instead of you
know 45 minutes a day I want to enjoy
that yeah well have you looked at that
that makes sense but let me ask you this
have you because see I'm now by the way
I want to be very clear because John did
a good job of saying from a math
standpoint if you're calling us does
this make sense financially you guys can
do this so it's a non-factor it's not a
bad decision but I'm actually done in
our playing off of your voice yeah and
what you're feeling and I heard now you
told us and thank you so here's the deal
what would make you feel really awesome
for 45
000.
are you a less cool Mom are you not who
you want to be in a 50 000 Sienna hybrid
that it can fit everybody and all the
luggage and gets about 45 miles a gallon
50 miles a gallon
I don't know what that is it's a it's a
Toyota minivan Toyota minivan yeah
that sounds terrible for me you nailed
it you nailed it that's what's going on
but what what sounds terrible the image
of yourself in that minivan
um just the idea of driving a minivan
okay but wait a second but wait a second
I'm going to keep pushing because John
gave you one option I'm gonna give you
another option what about a really
awesome SUV again that you can maybe get
for 45. maybe it's got a little bit
higher miles maybe it's got fifty
thousand sixty thousand miles but that's
nothing
yeah what's wrong with one of those
so I I just don't like the way that they
maneuver and so which one of you is from
Houston because driving around in one of
those yeah for an hour and a half in
Houston traffic is terrible so too lame
tiny Parts it is but also there's rocks
flying everywhere because they tear down
a new highway every other weekend for no
reason right so I mean it it goes back
to the ninety thousand dollar
depreciating asset that's going to be
destroyed on the outside and on the
inside I think of all the things I've
heard as we're thinking this out loud
it's what Ken said about what these four
kids crammed into this beautiful
wonderful car and if you call me and
said hey I got one kid or I'm single we
tell you dude buy it right now yeah I'd
be jealous of you because I'd love to
have that car
um but this is just us telling our
friend or our sister
dude kids destroy everything nuclear
scientists have found that goldfish Will
Survive those little treats those little
cheesy treats will survive a nuclear
blast yes and so they're definitely
gonna live in those crevices that even
your vacuum cleaner can't get to you
know the long neck you try to get can't
get it forever the world's greatest
adhesive melted gummy bear that sits
under or melted organic fruit snack
that's that's all you can eat in a Tesla
by the way and no matter what they tell
you about that awesome chemical you can
buy at your favorite store big box
stores your kid's gonna drop a smoothie
and it's going to stain that carpet
inside of six months and guess what it
ain't coming out nope nope hey buy what
you want to buy yeah you can do it I'm
more worried about you not liking
yourself in a vehicle that tells me you
got deeper things going on there that's
where I would start